vous avez vous avez vous avez une valise
jean-edouard la whey ce qui est
d'ailleurs qui ressemble un petit peu à
celle que david en loft mais n'ont
d'ailleurs non je vous ment parce que
celle-ci du loft a été très petit à
petit alors tous tous ont donc une
valise dans laquelle il ya une anecdote
formation qu'on ne connaîtrait pas
encore sur le loft j'ai quand même hâte
de voir ce que m'avait ramené genre
ailleurs parce que personnellement je
pense avoir absolument tout sur les
michaud alesi aux quelque chose en prit
alors la nzz pas trop ce qui est dedans
on attend quelqu'un avec lui alors posez
le sur la valise a alors c'est donc un
shaker à cocktail ah ouais bien chez
louvre
ben non je pense qu'il est vide je veux
pas mais alors à quoi on pouvait penser
ce shaker à l'alcool cwi absolue à huy
déjà c'est bien oui mais alors pourquoi
on vous a mis un shaker qui vous
rappellent de l'alcool en taille petite
idée moi oui
away with a fairy tale non non ils sont
c'est mélanger mais ce n'est pas avec de
l'eau et des glaçons alors 6ème de l'eau
par contre avec de l'eau alors racontez
nous non mais par contre je vois pas du
tout je vais écouter les sons les roses
et les navets ou des charges mais il y
en a une par une balle
le jour où on a lancé l'émission le
troisième jour le troisième jour voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui ça m'a fait un nom l'abus d'alcool
est dangereux pour la santé mais je dois
vous faire une confidence vrai qu'au
début de la téléréalité c'est à dire ça
a été un petit peu le cas pendant
quelques années on a vraiment fait gaffe
on a vraiment stopper les c'est vrai que
c'était plutôt open bar pour vous voilà
c'est vrai faut gagner un petit peu dans
le pays se trouve que le troisième jour
le 3 cd c'était une soirée et qui serait
mort oui et que s'est-il passé lors de
cette soirée
mais je sais pas si on a tous beaucoup
bu et chaud et moi j'allais prendre un
boss si vital est très bien c'est que
les gens connaissent pas mais alors et
il s'avère que bon bah je me suis
retrouvée garée
mais oui forcément quand on est le
gagnant ils sont mais bon on va droit au
but on a d'autres regardez les images
vous êtes vous et personne n'a oublié
ces images forcément le boul
[Musique]
physiquement il se rapproche de mon
idéal masculin à quelque chose près à la
chaux de fonds
roméo renonce à ton nom et à la place de
ce nom qui ne fait pas partie de toi
prends moi tout entière
je pense que ça nous arrive à tous de
temps en temps de prendre un peu de
plaisir non ce sera demain après demain
enfin quelqu'un dans mon lit [ __ ] moi
c'est qu'on perd on comprend avec les
chi ça se passe bien vous en reparle
loana bombe devant chansons où j'évolue
dans les franches mais ça ne veut pas
comprendre tant pis je n'ai pas forcé
n'ont plus rien c'est ce que je tente
donc un petit peu d'amour et que
j'aurais bien voulu reporter mon
affection sur quelqu'un mais sur un
autre signe un peu non là ça me fait
chier sacré jean edouard moi j'ai dit
mais là la quotidienne et j'avais trouvé
une formule 1 j'avais dit de vous était
passé du prince charmant au prince des
charmants et c'est vrai que à l'époque
alors qu quand on voit ça prouve qu'on
boit cul scarpati la base va pas se
mentir c'est pas toi ça avait fait ça
avait provoqué un tollé y avait les
proses dans les douars et des pros loi
là vous êtes rendu compte que vous avez
vous été pas cool avec elle quand même
sûrement que oui mais en même temps
j'avais 20 ans j'en ai bien après je
pourrais être un [ __ ] aujourd'hui même
temps j'ai aujourd'hui une femme
balistique que j'aime beaucoup et qui
j'avais un enfant
donc j'ai aucune raison le même le même
comportement mais enfin à l'époque je
pensais pas avoir fait quelque chose de
mal parce que c'était tellement facile
et ça s'est fait tellement vite c'est à
dire cinq minutes que je pensais pas à
ça mais la malade je pense cinq minutes
mais y arriver adacore chanteur brestois
merci
alors est-ce qu'il faut que vous sachiez
dedans sur 7 sur cette séquence à la
reprise on va aller on va pas en faire
tout maintenant pas est assuré mais
c'est pas genre j'ai commencé par ça
parce que les gens comprennent bien
avant cette séquence là le love se
chercher un peu forcément ça bien c'est
bien on s'est bien trouvés assure alors
ce que les gens savent pas forcément
c'est que vous étiez donc une soirée
sympathique mais c'est tombé sur vous
mais ça aurait pu ripper en faites pas
ça finalement
visiblement steve expliquer ce qui s'est
passé ben en fait on était tous les
trois mauvaise image et puis on revient
on était tous les trois et puis moi
j'avais juste une envie pressante donc
supporter au toilette pas faire si c'est
ça c'est pas ça obama version c nous
sommes tous les trois dans l'eau elle
commence loana commence à aller s'amuser
près de steve je me suis peut-être
trompé je peux te raconter parce que je
me rappelle parker j'ai une envie de
faire pipi
je suis parti aux toilettes après
qu'elle soit verte je suis parti aux
toilettes et là j'ai entendu tout le
monde vous tous la ferme
qu'est ce qui se passe at a raté son
coup donc en fait qu'en fait mais les
coulisses ouais on est à peu près aussi
qu'en fait elle est venue vers vous et
voilà à quoi s'était pas trop votre truc
ouais non mais c'est sa voix là où on va
on va appeler ça comme ça toilettes en
revanche
évidemment la question plein d'essence
dans l'émission on a des questions de
téléspectateurs
il réalise pour vous il ya une question
pour vous qui titille les suivantes
jean edouard et doit partir as-tu couché
avec loana dans loft par pure stratégie
alors c'est un oui mais je m'en doute
mais non mais de banon n'y avait pas de
stratégie dans le neuf le temps ça dont
il a raison on était les premiers mais
doit il n'y a pas de stratégie mais
c'est naturel et il n'y avait pas de
stratégie c'est à dire quant à moi quand
j'ai fait l'émission je pensais qu'il y
aurait un soir déjà
oui puis on avait oublié les caméras
nous au bout de ce salon mais alors
edwards était le plus jeune c'est pas
méchant de dire ça mais ce soir là j'ai
l'impression que toi aussi tu as un peu
moins bien vécue l'alcool que nous aussi
des fois je sais pas tu ne viens pas de
stratégie ou alors en l'occurrence ma
stratégie elle est bien merdique parce
que abane en baisse
oui parce que ça lui a coûté la victoire
est-ce que c'était la stratégie de loi
ne sera en tout cas pas ce soir parce
qu'on ne peut pas lui parler pendant un
temps merci